[Musique]
bonsoir
beaucoup plus coûteux qu'y a t'il
nounours j'en templeuve mais c'est vrai
on dirait un jeune chien qui gémit je
vais voir pauvre petit chemin il ne faut
pas le laisser pleurer
dépêche-toi nounours si tu veux rendre
visite à nicolas et pimprenelle ce soir
alors voilà le pauvre petit
pour voir millions pauvre petit chien
regard des patrons qu'il est joli où il
a été trouvé dans la rue tout seul il
pleurait il a peut-être fin il a dit
c'est perdre
qu'allons-nous infère nord j'ai une idée
je vais le confier à nicolas et
pimprenelle quelques jours juste le
temps de retrouver sa maison vient mots
gentils toutous je t'emmène tout de
suite tu vas d'ossements nounours qui ne
tombent pas aux pompes en
provenance ne vient pas ce soir
[Musique]
non je ne vous ai pas oubliés
regardez ce que je vous apporte sa
un pauvre petit chou peur du coup j'ai
trouvé dans la rue
[Musique]
c'est mignon
moi je crois qu'il un sommeil non il a
faim
[Musique]
monuc olemps prados à bébé chien du leur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pauvre petit du bon mot flamant au
ski les grands fait peur il serait quand
les enfants je crois que je peux me
confier sans crainte on va bien soigné
et tu vas je vais l'installer dans le
berceau de ma petit porsche
tient à six mois je vais essayer de
retrouver sa maison je vais mettre une
annonce dans le journal c'est quoi une
annonce quelques lignes écrites dans le
journal qui diront petit chien perdu
cherche sa famille
écrire ou téléphoner à nicolas ya pas
pro del cati qui s'interdit
la somme
oui il a summer
vous y êtes on va où guy
bonnier petit chien aurait
[Musique]
soixante
toutou
si on ne retrouve pas sa famille pouvoir
gâter oui il saura bien plus heureux
s'il retrouve sa maman chien c'est
encore à pépé allons en dormez-vous vite
et soigné le bien c'est brahmine 1,9 à
demain jeudi chronos bowden
[Musique]
dépêche-toi nounours il est tard les
enfants doivent aller se coucher et moi
je dois les mettre une annonce dans le
journal bonne ni les enfants embrasser
bien fort vos parents faites votre
toilette
n'oubliez pas de vous laver les dents
est fait pour
[Musique]